playwatchlisten is supported by patreon
who actually got this episode unedited
early and AD free if you want to support
the podcast check the link in the
description Mike Bethel I watch the menu
last week after you guys spoke about it
and then hyped me up on the idea of it
being a um dark comedy spoilers
everybody we're going to talk about the
menu uh I loved it good um good yeah and
I think that uh it stood out to me in
the same way that uncut gems did
same feeling both of those movies made
me want to vomit the whole time I mean
uncut gems genuinely felt like I'd taken
some bad drugs
absolutely it's so stressful I had a
biological reaction to that of like that
it's one of the you know people say like
oh you're gonna lean forward in your
feet whatever when you're watching
something uncut James is one of the only
movies where I was tensed and leaning
forward and just like oh my God please
stop this is awful
um the menu had a similar effect on me
where I the the tension of the whole
thing really got me uh and I love that I
never really knew of what they were
saying was true were they all gonna die
I don't know I I was like they probably
are but that could be a lie I don't know
is it a performance
um but I also like this
genre that you know has existed for a
long time but that I feel like is
recently we've gotten some good examples
of being things like the menu and knives
out where you get a cost of people who
you can hear one word from and
immediately know who they are like you
immediately understand that the shitty
um food critic
like what she's about and then the
partner who's constantly trying to
impress her and thinks she's incredible
like those two things so fast it was
like oh I get everyone in this room
straight away
um in a way that I think you could mess
that writing up by making it too too
much of a caricature but it's like
Return Of The Ensemble right like it
really feels like and and as you say
kind of quite broadly painted ensembles
and that's what makes them work right
because you do you just can clock the
archetypes and I've seen I've seen
knives out and the menu kind of
criticized for that and I think that's
the whole
they're meant to be like that they're
meant to be very readable at a glance
you know I know these 10 people yeah
because they're not the interesting part
like you the chef
um Ray finds his character whose name I
don't remember
um he's not like that
yeah and I think that's interesting not
everyone can be in the same way that I
think uh what's the uh Blanc he's he's
not a caricature either um so I think
like as long as you have at least one or
two characters that aren't like I don't
think Anna armis in the first Knives Out
was like that either
um having everyone else that way means
you just very quickly understand the
world that you're in and I also
I don't know if many people have spoken
about this I'm not really sure like I
read some reviews after watching it
which I tend to do with any movie that I
like or I read Reddit threads or what
I've just like see other people enjoying
a thing you like and um the fact that
they basically used
a sex worker being a sex worker as a
superpower
it was like that's [__] awesome the
fact that like they had to be like okay
she's effectively an escort I would
think
um and the superpower there is I know
exactly what to say to soothe this man
uh and I know exactly what this man
needs to hear from me uh in order to get
out of this situation and I was like God
that's so good because it makes sense
that you don't need that much more
context other than knowing a little bit
of a backstory or what she does for a
living to buy that happening to solve
many many big problems before this one
yeah and then you know I mean the guy
kind of dates an [__] as well right
like he's a absolute piece which is
beautifully right again he's lovely no
no one's ever like well you stupid girl
you should have come like that never
happens and I don't think I don't know
that I've ever seen any like want to
call it AAA even though that's not the
right word movie frame a sex worker in
that way that I was like Wow nobody ever
called her stupid [__] amazing that's
not [__] awesome like I just thought
it was something to tap into yeah and
but she also threw her presence I think
it's it's nice because it it shows and I
can't remember Ray finds his character
name either but it it shows the kind of
the not hypocrisy but the fact that he's
also in this hierarchy like everything
he's doing which is rebelling against
the awful customer basically he is then
himself as you say an awful customer
that she has to deal with yeah and it's
kind of there there's that kind of that
you know Turtles all the way down kind
of thing that's interesting and
definitely a part of what the film's
talking about because it's it's
definitely a film that kind of chat that
makes it very easy for you to look down
to just look at all these awesome Rich
[__] and hate them yeah but then
slowly deconstructs you know even if
you've never been to a Posh Restaurant
yeah like you've been this you've been
in this situation somewhere someone has
had to appease you you have been
accustomed totally been yeah
industry worker which is I think but
even if you've been in a service
industry there's still someone who's
serving you and oh totally that kind of
yeah yeah kind of exploring that was
interesting I think that's probably one
of my favorite themes that I think books
tend to explore more than movies and I
wish that like my brain creatively could
write that way because I love it it's
the idea of taking a really really
really simple criticism and then it was
in this case effectively blown up to a
sci-fi movie it's not really sci-fi but
the tone is sort of there in the
ridiculous it's Fantastical for sure
yeah and I mean even the way that
they're producing the food food the way
it's presented the the cult like like
it's it's just right it's definitely
particular restaurants that pretentious
I never have I don't know what kind of
money you got Mike I don't know that
I've ever been to a fancy restaurant to
be honest have you never have you know
I've I've been I've been taken to them a
couple times like on work trips that's
the one that stands out to me is the one
time that I went to this like amazing
rooftop restaurant in Paris with David
cage
and I didn't like the food I'm sorry
he
keeps me to uh in a way that like I'm
okay with
um to eat uh snail which is something I
didn't want to do
um David cage forcing you to eat snail
it's a little bit hard to say no I think
that's the only time though I don't know
that I've ever very similar famous games
person than situation I will tell you
the story of after this um I don't think
anyone's ever said that in an episode of
the show and I've not been like so what
were you gonna say yeah exactly it's
whatever yeah we'll do we'll do the
introductions we'll get back to it but
no I think but that's I I do I actually
I I I'm I do quite like gourmet food I'm
fascinated by that process and the
theater of it like the because the
Showmanship I me and Carrie watched it
together and we had like a few months
ago we'd been to like a nice restaurant
and and the introduction the chef coming
out and explaining to you the story he's
gonna tell you there's all the other
stuff that's 100 and that was one where
I'll be honest I remember in me and
Carrie in the restaurant kind of started
giggling a little bit kind of were in
the mood a little bit that was a bit too
much even for us but now I love there's
the the Artistry that's fascinating to
me I remember once going with some
friends too not frowning honored it all
for the record it's just I just don't oh
no I don't know my family doesn't really
have money but it does it Teeters on
that line of attention like I said I
usually usually I'm not the one picking
up the bill because I can't afford to
eat like that yeah that makes sense that
makes sense yeah true we're talking
about fancy gourmet restaurants gourmet
restaurants
best one I ever had was I was I went I
went to a restaurant with some friends
and I had um and one of the friends who
was there doesn't drink just doesn't
isn't isn't a drink it doesn't drink at
all and and you know mention no water no
liquidation
dry Foods only always but but obviously
you know usually there's like wine
pairings and and the um and they they
said to her oh no no problem we'll we'll
pair iced tea to your meal and I'm sat
there like this is iced tea and I was
like do no such thing no I said I said I
said to the later I was like so you're
gonna like put together different
non-alcoholic drinks for like as a
pairing for the meal and he's like yeah
we'll we'll do the flavor so I'm like
I'm having that please so me and her
just sat drinking iced tea with the meal
honestly like five glasses of iced tea
in that was interesting but they were
like trying to make everything balances
but if you go to a fancy restaurant like
that
that's the kind of thing you have to
book out like months in advance right no
no well I mean there is all there's a
tier of that kind of restaurant but they
don't let people like me are you a
foodie a lot of you seem like you would
be and and again I was saying I think
it's probably because my family doesn't
really have money so I just sort of
always sort of just like ate whatever
and I never I don't really have a
problem with eating the same Foods
repeatedly and I will say because this
video game podcast the one thing that
tends to make me crave crave different
food more than anything else is like a
game like a Yakuza or a Persona if I'm
playing something like Yakuza and you
know how you can see like the ramen you
like every time I'm like I guess I'm
eating Ramen like it works on me so much
more than advertising does
I mean that is also advertising of
course because you're talking about two
games have a lot of product places it's
true but I don't think that the ram is
obviously like like sponsored Ramen um
oh in the Yakuza 100 is it I think I
think I think in Yakuza if I'm
remembering right I think most of the
like food brands in Yakuza are probably
placement they are real I believe I
think that's true
is that also just not kind of like
indicative like having Coke in there
could be product placement but it's also
so inherent to the culture oh yeah it
gives authenticity right it adds to the
yeah they look so good then generic
brand Cola you know that doesn't feel as
organic yeah yeah 100 yeah it's that's
that's always been the the thing with
product placement is it adds yeah that
oscillation of like it it makes it
believably part of that world makes
sense yeah what are we supposed to be
talking about right now
I said that I've never been to a
restaurant like that that like do you
feel that like indulgent experiences
like that in a restaurant are a waste I
don't have an opinion on it really some
people do like I'm just gonna [__] it
out later what's the point and other
people are like
I have I have friends that were I was
just talking about this with someone
like a waste of resources or yeah it's
kind of like what's what's the point of
bringing somebody flowers you're just
gonna die but with a meal or whatever
I'm I'm that guy's like do you remember
that bottle of wine that we had and such
and such was like there there's a
there's an experience I will pay
anything that I'm capable of for a good
experience
like I went to the Super Bowl that was
not cheap I mean I got really really
cheap tickets but that I don't care
about football still cheap tickets are
still a horse bit dude save for it um
but that was a thing that I was like
whoa It's in my home City this is an
experience I don't care about football
but that I will pay a lot of money for
experiences of anything else do I think
that like fine dining is wasteful I
think only if you were to do it
extremely frequently maybe because I
think like
food is art
that's why I was gonna say I like
watching artists work like for me the I
don't go when I I know you know whenever
I've done that kind of thing it's never
been it's not it's not the the status of
doing it because [__] those guys but
like the I just love seeing someone
who's very good at what they do do the
thing that they're good at but you're
also that endlessly fascinating you're
supporting an artist in a lot of cases
there right rather than a chain
in a lot of cases not all of them
obviously that can be Michelin star
chains I don't know yeah but there's
investors it's it's it's kind of one of
the same things it's not the menu proves
that as well true huh no it's not
McDonald's McDonald's
they're artists they're they're crafts
thank you
and McDonald's is it could be a
franchise store which means you were
specifically yeah supporting that guy or
that girl who open who spent 65 000 or
whatever it is to open a McDonald's so
although franchising is fascinating if
you ever want to look into like the
business of franchising that Subway
thing that John Oliver did
what are you talking about
oh it's too much to get into but
needless to say if you if you want to do
a deep dive into how Subway works as a
company John Oliver Subway I watched
most of his videos I just must have
missed that one yeah I was like I'll
never get it again well a lot of it
reminds me as well of like Licensing in
games right like if you're working with
an IP or you're working with a platform
holder or you're on a platform which is
95 of video games run fall into one of
those categories then a lot of that
franchising model stuff starts to I'm
very curious about how Warhammer 40K
works because they have a lot of games
yeah a lot of games
um I don't know if it's a situation
where somebody goes to them and just
pitches an idea and they get publisher
money they have they come out with so
many games for that IP oh they make it
known that that IP is available like I
don't think I'm talking out of school to
say like I mean I've been approached
like they they if you're a developer who
makes stuff that's like does okay and is
relatively or I'll see you've had a call
from them at some point like that
they're very they don't wait for people
to come back
what's the deal what kind of whatever
game you want I'm available
uh post-apocalyptic uh he's a black
market Smuggler and he's trying we got
you but it is franchising right like
that that is very similar like that is
then basically going out and going we
have this value
a recognizable brand you can put in
something second sorry it's the biggest
one I can think of in games I mean Star
Wars recently but that was still like EA
license
um otherwise I think what Konami is
currently doing with Silent Hill
there are what they announced four or
five games from different Studios I
don't think any of them that many I know
two yeah I think there's there's no no
code one but the Remake which is uh
bluebow
um I don't remember the names of all of
them but it's I think it's four or five
are they trying to Assassin's Creed
themselves is that is that like I don't
know it's really interesting responsible
like that's the thing is and but there's
different Souls of thought of that
because there's also license holders
um and obviously I've because we've done
a couple of them I've spoken to most of
the big ones they will they will
actively not want to make too many stuff
with too much stuff for their IP because
they want it to feel and this is like
franchising in the sense of how many
Subways you put on the street right like
they don't want to create they don't
want their brand to be so ubiquitous
that loses value oh or they want to
protect like a window of release where
they'll say okay well we only want we
don't want more than one game a year
that's tied to this I was in a game once
that was too close to
the game that was going to come out
later that they were really kind of
putting some more stuff behind so we
were all the way done they were I mean
box art ready and they ended up going
burn the discs we're not releasing it
because it cost them too much to release
the game yep that's crazy that's uh
they're like Far Cry 3 by the way was
supposed to be kind of like an
in-between title
interesting yeah and then it was like oh
we have a I have a hit I'm sorry Far Cry
4. yeah no way oh this guy
I was gonna say it's it's funny that yo
so much about Far Cry 3 yeah that's
weird
uh yeah I I know that like there are
stories that I'm definitely aware of
of a video game that was supposed to
come out and then one pushed and so
another one pushed like that's not a
myth that does happen but generally from
what I'm aware of it happens from the
same publisher the publisher pushes
their own games to separate them among
the borders less so happens with
competitors
you will that's that's true I mean the
big the big ones like if you're if you
like you know the Call of Duties of this
world back in the day I don't know if
that would still be true nowadays but
like the When the Call of Duties of
other worlds of other worlds the
Multiverse of Call of Duty games like
that 100 like games would get just
pushed away from but yeah no Publishers
Publishers IP holders everyone they
don't want to oversaturate and also they
have finite resource right so they so
putting out two big games close together
costs them twice as much and also could
cannibalize each other's sales right
that's happened many times and just the
same quarter you don't want all your
sales in the same quarter because you
you want to be able to retain that
income let me check that the amount of
new Silent Hill games that we have
because I really thought that was an
interesting one dead silent and then
they have a conference where they
announce several and they're all from
different Studios this is after Konami
had been very forward about wanting to
go all out in nfts obviously konami's
got a big gym business in Japan uh but
also Pachinko like
really unexpected thing that I think I'm
excited about for the most part I feel
pretty positively about it so there's
the Silent Hill too did you say you're
excited about nfts that's why I did not
Troy I did not say that this is now it's
this is now the second nft intervention
on the count on the camera
switch places
we're all here we very much love you
what's up I wanted to share this Troy
you want to go first why no Metal Gear
Solid
did they do a pump fake where they like
announced it and then they want it back
no no I just I'm just surprised that Mel
gear is not being exploited given its
reputation like silent as you say Silent
Hill we've got a bunch of stuff Silent
Hill 2 remix I I suspect a lot of people
just don't want to follow in those
footsteps because they're so good the
last time I know it's a concern Silent
Hill Town fall
which is annapona
um but the developer is no code Studio
so it's you look great so it's being in
partly it's John McCallum how does that
work yeah I know that's what I'm
thinking how is working on a common army
game
is it a couple that was your deal no
it'll be it'll be a licensed it'll be an
IP licensing deal so the key thing the
key interesting thing there that I think
people know publishing konami's just
given the license
yeah well no konami's probably selling
the license that's the thing I think
people don't understand often with
licensing is probably konami's not
putting any money into that but I don't
know anything about this project to be
clear sorry I'm just realizing this is a
project
details are there any of this but why
Wilson but like no often with like this
is a licensing deal so a license or will
sell effectively like the rights to make
something based on ipx
probably an entrepreneur is paying for
the development they've probably they've
either done it they've done a deal with
Konami for the rights to you Silent Hill
in that and they put the whole project
together you know if that's generally
something where they get paid like
royalties is it based on sales or is
that a flat rate kind of thing it's like
so it's very variable like it's very
variable from contract to contract you
can it can be an upfront payment for IP
it can be a percentage it can be a
combination it really depends and it
depends as well on like what VIP is even
like you know you've worked on IP it's
like like a little bit different from
from your deals
on my side yeah
um nuanced I'm gonna say just nuanced
like there's been yeah there's been
differences there's been differences but
obviously I can't talk anything very
coached response I can't expect to be
able to give me details so this is how
much money
I'm trying to fill the [__] frame I
just want to put it over here
um I was looking at something which I
was like that's really [__] rude
that's great
um when Batman The Telltale series came
out obviously that was a licensed thing
that Telltale that's what they did they
licensed Walking Dead they licensed Game
of Thrones they license everything I was
trying to figure out who the publisher
was because I think Telltale
self-published my self-published yeah
but this was published by WB Games well
it says that it was published by
Telltale Games and distributed by webe
so
we'll have a distribution so I do that I
think when they've distributed physical
copies of games they've done that via
Partners always right I think back in
the days
was it 2K or
I feel like is that something I think
even uh sometimes distributions
different based on country as well
sometimes they have different
distributors based on the countries
would you say it's a safe assumption to
say when somebody golly that's a very
literative sentence when somebody
self-publishes that means that they're
essentially funding it themselves
that would be the traditional meaning of
self-publishing but you often there's a
lot of there's like there's every kind
of deal like there's investors there's
there's people buying writing companies
there's like Indie Games
handshake deals there's there's so many
different shapes of there are 5 000 ways
to fund a video again but I still think
generally that's that is what that means
is they are yeah yeah self-publishing
would be usually that would mean
although not always not always true uh
Silent Hill F don't know who's making
this one it is set in 1960 Japan and it
looks very cool it's it's a racing game
it's written by um
a well-known murder mystery horror
visual novelist who I believe goes by
rauchishi 07
um who people seem to be very excited
about Silent Hill Ascension
this is being made by gen Vega
entertainment and Bad Robot Games
Behavior interactive entertainment
yeah do you it's an okay interactive
Digital streaming Series where the
community plays and shapes the game
together according to Konami that's
interesting
cool yeah and then return
I wanna I want a full description of
Troy's facial expression for no reason
by the way I'm being caustic for no
reason whatsoever oh really bad robot
what kind of stupid name for a company I
love being genuine because I wasn't
looking at your face I was like oh
Troy's really into this one no
uh and then yeah let's get to know that
my tone is kind of like it's not
bad's first game
I'm not sure maybe but that's a big
collaboration
um and then sorry and then return to
Silent Hill
oh that's the movie
which I actually like the first I don't
know maybe
um we talk about adaptations
[Laughter]
how are we talking about the menu again
I'm sorry there's two things that I Was
preparing by being the Nicholas Hull
character from the menu That's What
ruined the conversation about the menu
people like fine dining I think is the
question he asked me
um thank you all for uh indulging me
while I I did my caloric intake for the
day no worse any time not the day
um
two things I was prepared to talk about
by the way well I guess three we could
talk about yeah
because I mean everything else I'll just
kind of talk out of my ass we all know
that your writers arrived right like we
have you've got your M Ms right we're
good to go yeah but we need to talk
about the color okay we'll have a
conversation offline
um there's to be super relevant we could
talk about the Oscar nominations oh I
didn't see them oh I saw that you're
super happy about that
um everything everywhere all at once
leads with 11. my favorite nominations
11 nominations no surprise here Brendan
Fraser nominated for the whales see that
is that good if we see as I know have I
never seen whale I've not seen that yet
I have a feeling he's gonna take it
um for Elvis yeah I think Austin
Butler's got a good chance
we'll see I do think your probably right
Brendan Fraser will take it I think
Brenda Frank's going to like because we
have to remember it's a committee it's
people well and there's no story it's
very how nice yeah everybody loves a
comeback story like that's that's and
that's kind of been the the you look at
the Golden Globes and that kind of is
like a precursor
getting nominated is great did the
Oscars I once I once uh have I told you
have I told my Bill Nye story on the
show that might be a new anime I want to
hear it again we um me and Carrie were
driving through London Carrie and I
Carrie and I whatever
um and uh can I coach you on the English
language
yeah no I I need the help the the
hilarious thing is I have to go through
every script I write and correct for
those and it's that and who apostrophe
yes
Cory McCarthy doesn't give a [__] about
grammatical errors I'm sticking the
landing here so so we were driving
through London and we came up to a
Crossing I think it was
God where were we was it Beau or Milan
somewhere around there and um
guy older guy who just like walks across
the street in front of us and me and
Carrie just changing I'm like oh oh [__]
that's Bill Nye and the the I didn't
know the windows of the car were open
and there was no noise around and he
stopped in the middle of the road turned
around gave us the exact facial
expression you think Bill Dai would give
us and said actually it is yeah
that's incredible [__] amazing so I
hope he wins he deserves it for that
I love him Paul mascal for after sun
that's not a surprise well yeah it's I'm
only hearing about it because of people
like propping it up
um and Colin Farrell for Banshees of
information
yeah the uh uh Colin Farrell for the
band shoes that enter sorry
um that's weird
I was saying it flawlessly and it's
really bothering me
yes he's a wonderful actor oh
picture
holy [__]
this is news to me we landed on the moon
but news to nobody else at this point
top gun Maverick it's a great movie so
do I great movie but just for the fact
that it gets nominated
that's not a movie you get nominated for
it's true yeah that's amazing it's a the
spectacle of that movie is not to be
understated even though it's very
actioning what they actually do is is
incredible the fact that all of the
pilots were actually in Jets like oh I
love that movie I met some people like
well I have some friends who really
didn't like it and I was like I
understand yeah
women talking parentheses no men
listening uh Francis McDormand LED that
that's nominated for Best Picture
everything everywhere all at once that's
very good my favorite movie of the year
all right banshees of interference is
also being nominated
uh triangle to apologies to all of our
uh six of our Irish listeners
I do know how to properly say Ireland as
opposed to Ireland Ireland uh triangle
of sadness I heard that's really good
and it's one of those ones I haven't
watched that somebody recently was like
just watch it and don't look anything up
about it so I've heard it's better than
the TR it's another one where the
trailer is about the first 30 minutes
and apparently after that it gets much
more interesting because the trailer
really put me off I wish the trailer was
like I don't think
um wait Francis McDormand
I'm trying to understand how many
instances have there been of people like
of an actor being nominated for like
best picture twice or like a an actor
that's in more than one best picture
review
that's a pop quiz question right there
I'm trying to figure out the the listing
of because it's best pictures so
typically that is listed by the director
and the producer but like I'm seeing
here Tom Cruise must have been a
producer on it Brooke Heimer obviously
uh Christopher McQueary was the director
uh but women talking Francis McDormand
is was she a producer or the director
Chris Macquarie didn't direct is Chris
Chris macari didn't Direct topgum he
wrote it I think wrote it sorry sorry
um
Martin oh so I didn't realize the
Banshees was McDonough movie I have to
see it now
um I'm just trying to figure out if
women talking is Francis McDormand
directing
let's have a look let me check it out
all right you know invent a tool where
we could check that what an avatar for
best picture it's also really surprising
but I really enjoyed Avatar we've not
talked about Avatar on the show I really
enjoyed it it's great it sure I know
it's problematically I've never I
haven't seen it I just I think spectacle
is wonderful but I would love for
something else to be
um look at that Argentina got nominated
for international feature film but my
Western friends spectacle was like again
I didn't watch Avatar because it doesn't
interest me but
I think that's one of those ones that
could be nominated for technical feat
like best picture is is a whole other
thing but I think it's one of those you
give somebody seven years to shoot a
movie and yeah or 15 years later I'm
gonna stand up for camera and I think
it's great like I think again he's doing
what Lucas was doing in the 70s like
he's pushing the media the the
technology and the process Lucas also
shot that in a summer so versus I mean
it's um
changing the tech and I I actually even
and I mean always has done that that's
what I love about James Cameron great
and I'm also inclined to think that even
what they did with Avatar is likely to
help video games too uh it certainly has
you know how many stages I've shot of
those like they shot Avatar here to be
clear like how much of your job exists
the parts of your job exists because of
Technology pioneered on the first avatar
like not just James Cameron I mean a lot
of performance capture technology a lot
of it is a lot of it is Bob zimekus
because he was the one who was really
going I think we can do something with
this
because you have everything from Polar
to
um uh what's the big one the [__]
Beowulf
um there's there's a lot of those that
were kind of precursors James Cameron
took that and obviously built upon it
not I'm not knocking him at all and I
have a lot of people that have worked
with them and and speak very highly of
them and also people that have worked
with them and don't speak highly of them
um there's no doubt like if you just do
a a behind the scenes for the abyss and
you can see he created a whole new tech
of how to record audio underwater it's
like it's amazing what he did
um I just don't know if that's I I
Lament The James Cameron of the 90s
Island met like T2 and and stuff like
that I watch I watch Avatar too and I
still see that like the like in terms of
like just action choreographers doing a
little attack aside the way he can tell
a story and especially I really like the
script and Avatar too I think that's a
massive really like I think it looks
like that
it's still very it's still very Mythic
it's still very big broad Strokes kind
of like we were talking about earlier
with kind of using stereotypes as a way
into a story but I think it's I think
it's pretty pretty great to be honest
but I like the first avatar so you know
your mileage may vary yeah I thought
that was fine
Michelle Williams Kate Blanchette
Anna De armas got nominated for a movie
that she's no longer in
she's
been awesome quietly in movies for so
long okay Michelle yo no no shock there
uh best animated feature
Marcel the Shell with Shoes On okay
I'm so happy to see this Puss in Boots
the last wish it looks really good it
I've seen it three times it's it's
traveler's first movie in the theater
um it is first of all it's hilarious
um it is a wonderful poetic tale I think
of just I love it whenever a franchise
admits that it may be getting long in
the tooth
and it's like what are we doing here and
they they take that and they imbue it
into the story of uh his character and
be like
should we keep doing this what what is
the point of doing this and and it's a
deal with our own mortality it's a deal
with finding your true self it's it's
it's absolutely great
um I I wanted to point this out it's I
laughed so hard in a couple of times
one nomination so uh lost onions a
Knives Out mystery is under writing
adapted screenplay
interesting not original screenplay
well maybe someone took it and adapted
it was there a story originated it must
have been it must have been based on a
story it still it says written by Ryan
Johnson but that that's the adapted
screenplay which I had I know that's one
of the categories that's like comedy and
musicals it's one of those categories
where there's some weird like Clauses
because I think Top Guns up for adapted
screen games as well despite being like
oh [__] this makes so much sense
uh I'm looking at best original score
Babylon
everything everywhere all at once the
Banshees and
um
Carter Burwell
that's no shock and the fablemans John
Williams getting his
97th Oscar nomination wow
all quiet and that's I don't know it's
97 I don't know I decided I say stuff
because you say it so confidently
where's Austin
we're chime in there
what happened
um All Quiet on the Western Front I'm
going to say this again to just annoy
him as he's watching this later volcker
bertelman who's I don't know who that is
he's gonna be like how can you not
possibly know who that person is he was
the person who
Best Supporting Angela at first that All
Quiet on the Western Front was that Gina
Carano movie and I was like that
copyrighted you know the daily wire
movie that made like 800.
Carrie Condon Jamie Lee Curtis Stephanie
Sue
I always mess up this
and uh hongshao for the whale I really
should see the whale Mark McDonough got
a nomination
[__] a right he did good for him
no I just think he's really talented I
love all of his movies
uh Todd field for r
yeah guitar is showing up a few times
I'm not sure it's just one of the ones
that it it feels like ooh quick stick
what about the composer feels like it is
because that's the cover art that I've
seen the international world of
classical music film sent his own Lydia
tar
you go up and coming director Steven
Spielberg
got nominated he might do all right how
are there two directors for everything
everywhere all at once
go directly one each Multiverse there's
more than
my friend
spoiler
man best visual effects no doubt here
Batman Avatar quiet Black Panther and
Top Gun yeah I mean that's got to be
tough gunshots
gun facial effects breakdown because
every visual effects artist I've heard
from says that there's so many more
visual effects in Top Gun than you
realize I would love to see
speaking of relevant things that's been
breaking my brain with Last of Us with
episode two was knowing of some of those
things aren't real and being like [__]
that looks good
I I thank you for that wonderful segue
that was Sunday night was the first
night for me to be able to see it we
were sitting with Neil and and Craig and
and watching it in Neil's house and it's
the first time for me to see it finished
and I was laughing because I was like
holy [__] like that I I've seen what
that shot looks like where Ellie's
walking across the plank of wood that is
a blue screen behind her and that's it
it's on a Sound Stage
um the Rotunda
the Rotunda they built but so many
visual effects that you would not
believe were not there uh on the day
sideways building when they first walked
out that I was like I know that's not
real I can't tell you how it's not real
can't tell it was it was blue blue
screen with with white crosses no way
and they're giving you that performance
looking over the edge into where all of
the infected are not there at all damn
walking across the bridge and they're
just being the highway not there at all
visual effects team [__] sleep it
might be some of the best it's still at
their most expensive episode that's
coming how do you with the with the
podcast do you do that do you watch each
episode all together and then go and
record the episode of the power
I started watching them because I was I
was like I want to see all of these and
we started doing the podcast and they
were like I was like in this episode it
was fantastic that this happened they're
like great real quick that happens in
the next episode and went buck and I
started conflating where certain things
happen
um so I had to be diligent and go I'm
only going to watch episode four which
is one of five uh right before we do the
podcast and so
um we just we have one more episode of
the podcast to do and we are done so
we're kind of that far yeah
no so one more we gotta do yeah
literally they haven't finished the
episode yet is that what you wait on
basically they have almost finished
um mixing and everything the TV's close
right TV they are putting them this is
coming episode together as the first
episode's airing episode five and six
were the last two I got enough Troy
every week no I didn't want to listen to
it because I wanted to watch the show
I'm gonna watch it twice I figured I'm
gonna watch it once without that
commentary because I don't I want to
fill in the blanks myself in general
conclusions and be wrong and enjoy that
and then you know whatever and then I'm
gonna listen to the podcast and then
watch it again and I thought that would
be the best way to do it they're at 100
there's stuff that even people like HBO
IGA was pointing out they're like watch
it again did you see this like when
Nana's in the chair in the first episode
if you look at the reflection in
um of her in the TV you can see tendrils
in her mouth
me chills there's all sorts of stuff
there is not a single frame that's
unintentional yeah I don't doubt it um I
don't even question I even thought I
caught Craig on something I was like not
to be you know too much of a dick but
pointing this out he goes actually to
point this out to you and he corrected
me I was like dude the guy knows it in
and out in and out and you are so not
ready for the next week's episode so
made me like extra excited about it if I
if I was like over taught it was like
you gotta hype it up a little bit
I would feel bad but I'm not I'm just
you're you're gonna that's all you're
saying though you're not telling me it's
incredible you're just saying watch out
for it so I don't know what I'm
anticipating I'm anticipating something
I will say this everything is to taste
however I think there are very few
examples of
whatever the show is I could say I could
we could be talking about a sugar like I
don't think I want to watch that show be
like tell you what watch this one
episode and even if you don't watch the
rest of the series you can you don't
need to know anything else about the
series just watch this one episode as a
purely Standalone episode of Television
I could show you episode three and not
knowing anything about the world
anything about the characters anything
about any of it it is a beautiful
beautiful episode and it is
I love that what what Craig calls
um emotional action sequences like
emotional action scenes
and in a lot of ways we have more of
those than we do big set pieces what's
the definition there is that is is it
what makes what makes it what makes an
emotional scene an action an emotional
travel that happens in terms of the
characters or I would say that there's
just as much happening underneath the
surface as a crumbling building that's
on fire exploding and smashing it's
about intensity of or sorry uh density
of detail in there density is a great
way to put that I think what is
happening between two characters whether
they be a dialogue or not that is an
emotional action and it's we there's
there's something happening to these
characters and you don't have to rely on
all of this external stuff there's a lot
of trust in in these episodes like you
know that's such a great job of letting
things live in a look
um and there was even times when there
were people in the castle were like I
don't know if we should do that he
wasn't I need to trust me on this one
and I'm seeing people point that out
going I'm really glad that this happened
and that we paid homage to this and how
that translated from the game into this
and a lot of those are just looks I I
mean I would say that I do have a lot of
trust in it because one thing that's
like very very different uh from my
perspective between the show and the
game at this point I just restarted it
started replaying part one
um is Ellie when you first meet her in
the game is a lot softer nicer she's a
little bit more willing to go with them
uh she doesn't attack troll on site very
soft in comparison to the show and with
the show I was like she's a lot more
hostile she's a lot harsher like for
them to get this relationship to work
where he ends up you know basically
being in love with her like she's a
daughter that's quite a journey to go on
from where she is in his first two
episodes but I've never been more sure
that something is going to do that I'm
like can't wait to see like I'm not like
I don't know about this I'm like it'll
be great like there's just I just feel
like what Craig did was he exploited a
lot of the things that were already
there and again it's it's enriching and
it's building upon it so I think there's
layers of Ellie that were always there
that you're just now seeing and there's
layers of Joel that you I've always been
there that you're are you're seeing more
of I mean Tess is way more fleshed out I
think
did a fantastic job and there's there's
other cool stuff that we were able so I
keep saying we this has been very kind
about bringing me into it so I do feel
the sense of ownership Beyond just just
me
but um
I guess in the same way that you talk
about your football team when I was like
we did a great job on Sunday
um
but you're not taking credit for it
you're fine
yeah no
um but there's some stuff that they did
like specifically Pedro
um that you saw like his hand
and him saying it's a hairline fracture
uh it'll heal fast
it's like we have to admit the fact that
literally in a game you can't do that
because it feels forced well you also
can't call attention to it like you're
kind of you're doing The Stance of not
wanting to explore the real mortality of
the characters in that way like yeah but
also like you're you're in contrast with
your mechanic yeah exactly yeah
narrative dissonance I don't know if
you've heard the phrase Before Troy but
that's the thing you're trying to avoid
yeah so in in the show we don't have
that and in some ways we have to make it
more they get to have an amp up the
violence in the game a lot of times
because there's a lot of it and it it's
progressively worse you know and we'll
see examples of that later on in the
show but this is a perfect case to go
remember these are real people in a very
real world that's why opening up with
that lovely scene in Jakarta oh my God
it was so good dude every now and then I
watch something where I'm like if you
just took this 10 minutes this 15 minute
chunk and you gave it to me as a short
film I'd be like holy [__] [__] it's
perfect and then having that inside of
something else that's very good that oh
that those performances were incredible
they were so good and the tension of
sorry for spoilers we should have given
a spoiler warning I've not watched it
yet but you can okay I'll be I'll be
vague but like the the
scene of her being asked what to do and
the way that she answers and then she's
like they're like what do you want to do
and she's like be with my family that my
stomach sank I was like there were the
way that you've sold the reality of this
just [__] hell it's such a good 10 I
don't know how long it was but it's
perfect incredible I love that expansion
I love that they're going and doing yeah
it's little flashbacks yeah canvas the
beauty of it is also uh
it's it's again adding weight to things
that we are either as fans expecting
or B
um explaining people explaining things
you're about just to a whole new
audience when you see this huge crater
and there's a line that's taken directly
from the game
you get to you we get to show it yeah
it's like hey here's an opportunity to
say why does this look like a [__] up
Moon yeah it's well because we tried to
bomb I'm doing this weekly Roundup
podcast thing with different guests
um every week after the episodes and
because I tweeted asking if people
wanted to join both Mike Flanagan and
Kate Siegel replied which I already told
you Troy so I'm going to have them on an
episode and I'm excited to have them
because they'll probably be the only
guests that I have who won't have played
the game right um and I'm I'm very
excited to see their perspective and to
get to ask somebody especially like you
know those two who who love that kind of
media to see what they think of it and
uh how they feel about the the economy
but it does seem to be crossing over
right like I've seen I've seen enough
kind of people who are not game people
kind of yeah
my parents will watch it it'll take off
anywhere there are definitely people who
are not a part of this genre or world
and video games either that are I'm
hearing from them they're like totally
into it yeah it's the hardest thing in
the world I assume you've played this
game and I'm like yeah of course like
explaining something explaining do like
the thing you were saying Troy of
basically like walking other people into
it when you're knowledgeable about
something the hardest thing in the world
is to introduce is to know what the path
in is it's the same thing we find like
you know doing like a tutorial in the
game is the hardest thing in the world
because everyone on the team knows how
the game is played intimately and
perfectly so actually working out the
steps for that is fascinating and that's
it I imagine the same is true here if
you're a fan of The Last of Us game
knowing how to tell that story that's
you have to go outside yourself and
think from such a a third person
perspective it's fascinating not only
telling the the story but also just
components of the world spoiler for the
podcast it's a wonderful moment where I
pointed out something that Pedro did in
the episode I was like oh it's so good
we see this a lot with the shh
they can see or that they can hear but
they can't see
and Neil goes that was a reshoot and I
went
wait what they go we thought
oh this will be enough for us to be able
to convey to the audience
how they see because everybody knows
what a clicker is and HBO went got a
question for you what we don't
understand what's happening right now
why can't they see them they're like
well they don't have eyes they're like
we don't know we just see this thing out
of their face they're like got it so
they had to do a reshoot that said just
to make sure at least never seen this
either so Ellie is the audience yeah and
she all she says is I've heard that
there's these possible things out here
and tessen and Joel look at each other
and go are we going to confirm this or
not what does she know we know that
they've seen them
and that's when he does that thing was
like I need to teach you right now they
can't see but they can hear shut the
[__] up which is why he says from this
point forward we are silent not quiet
silent and it immediately with that sets
the tension woof I find that fascinating
because that's I guess the reshoots it's
it's well screenings and reshoots is the
closest I guess you get to like play
testing it's been it's been a thing with
with this is you know working on Tron
there's a big chunk of the audience who
are too young that they probably don't
100 a lot of this law so it's been my
job to kind of pull this law in it's a
similar process and then work out ways
of kind of introducing people to kind of
what that world is
um it's fascinating kind of trying to
pick that apart and and then exactly as
as you said like showing it to people
and being like do you get this and
having someone go so what they're inside
a computer it's like oh we never told
anyone they were inside a computer oh
[__] yeah oh God I gotta go back so
something again I'm doing this play
through that I'm so far really enjoying
where I'm gonna watch an episode of the
show and then play up to that point in
the game which I think is actually going
to be pretty hard for episode three I'm
expecting that to be a pretty long chunk
of gameplay but uh the the speed of
things like for the TV comparison like
how quickly you meet Ellie in the game
versus in the TV show a lot of those
things are sped up way more than I would
have expected and then different things
have slowed down and seeing the pacing
differences between the two mediums was
something that I found very interesting
and I kept taking what I think Troy you
said last week or the week before and
thinking about it which is certain
things no matter what we say just don't
translate to TV certain things just
won't work you you can't the the test
situation probably couldn't have worked
the other way I'm trying to speak around
spoilers for you Mike
um because it's
uh probably too off footing to your
average audience
um so the the change to that I think
there's a lot of sense Sports don't make
any sense in a TV show make perfect
sense in a game I think Pedro Pascal
wants to wear a mask for a home well
it's beautiful
we've we've put up with too many masks
over this place over the years I think
it's not there's like that would that
would just not work and so here's an
opportunity to go game needed that and
we wanted that but then that that sets
up the questions like well then that was
a very Pinnacle moment in the game of
how we how are you breathing that in
so we don't have that moment anymore oh
[__] well what do we got to do now we
have to have this moment and so it's I I
David Lindelof and and the whole team on
Game of Thrones I realize they're like
well we don't have to do that or let's
do this here and like dude you go one
degree off in a long enough direction
and you are a far cry from The Source
material so I think Craig I think HBO is
also very cognizant of that and I also
think that
um Craig and Neil are cognizant of that
and the beauty is they have these
conversations where they go
what is the story about this story is
about
the the love of a parent to a child okay
so does this speak to that if it does
[__] it great do it if it doesn't it
goes that's all that matters is such a
useful thing in writing it's so useful
like they talk about that with uh God of
War 2018. what is that game about in
theory spreading the ash at the top of
the mountain that's what that's the Crux
of the game that's what the plan knows
that they have yeah constantly trying to
do that is the game spread Ashes to top
of mountain and having that thing to
constantly reminds you of what you're
doing the whole way through this is
about the love between a father and a
daughter that's effectively what the
whole thing is is so good to write with
to remember every scene it's such a a a
through line that really keeps you going
and also because Craig and Neil are
coming at it from the position that they
are they look at that we're not putting
oh yeah
oh yeah and so that's what I this is one
of the things that I respect most about
Neil
is that when he wrote this this was a I
don't think he did what do you mean
you you cut out you said here's the
thing I really respect about me
oh [__] there we go
um when he wrote this his daughter had
just been born right so he had had an
idea of like this for a while but it was
different versions of different
permutations and I'll let him get to
that on the podcast
but
um
there was a he wrote this as a as a
thought experiment as a dad what do I
look like
in the event of this tragedy what do I
look like if I lose my daughter how far
would I go to protect her what would I
do so he's writing very very personally
so is Craig Craig is writing very very
personally as well and so you take the
two of their experiences and you put
them into the same story that's where
you get this holy [__] it feels so
grounded and it is 100 Guided by what
does the love of a parent to a child and
that's not always pretty sometimes that
is terrifying and if you agree where
North is you can take different Journeys
right totally if you agree on way your
head is so helpful to have that end goal
um Trey I think I saw like maybe IG and
ask you this or something but yeah
they'd only be able to give you a tiny
answer
um you are not a father when you played
Joel the first time you now are has that
like totally correct I might have even
asked you this question has that totally
reframed how you feel about
totally I understand Jill's decision
more than I did when I was shooting the
scene um
um I do not think that I
could go back and shoot that scene again
with Sarah and if I did I don't know
what it would look like
um
it both terrifies me and like intrigues
me to think if I had to reshoot that
scene not be able to think about the sun
even when we did it on the One Night
Live still wasn't a dad it there's just
something that changes and I don't think
that that means people say do I have to
play the game in order to enjoy the show
by the same token you don't have to be a
parent to appreciate the show but if
you've played the game you will
appreciate the show on a completely
different level just as if you are a
parent you will appreciate the story on
a completely different level but it hits
on every level because at the end of the
day what we're talking about the
currency of the conversation is love
yeah what does love look like and love
is
ugly love is terrifying love is
controlling love is like a fungus that
spreads and grows
laughs
nice visual gag from Mike before they
audio listeners thank you have fun some
people are going to put [__] in your
mouth now Mike
it's a Snapchat filter just like
tendrils coming out of Mike's mouth do
it do it bfx me let's do it yeah I I was
super impressed by this episode visually
I've been I don't know I feel like I
spent a lot of time like like I watched
Velma because I was curious about why
everyone disliked it so much is it is it
as bad as it is
no but what it does do that again in my
opinion obviously what it does do that's
bad I think is very bad um and also very
bizarre I it it seems like the show has
a misunderstanding of satire it's very
strange there are scenes over and over
and over and over again where a
character will make a reference to other
TV and go like there are these lesbian
cops and Velma goes I thought you guys
were supposed to be good at solving
crimes it's like the one thing that
lesbian cops are good at on every TV
show and then two minutes later there's
a well the reason all the kids hang out
at the diner usually in other movies is
because of the Italian man who's got a
nice blah blah blah and it's just
constantly referencing and criticizing
themes in other TV shows shows that half
of the time I haven't understood like
I'm like is that it's like that's I
didn't know that's hello fellow kids
very kind of just happy this is a
universal experience right okay well so
the the guy who wrote the first episode
um I don't know about the rest of the
show I know mini K league is being
attributed as a writer but I don't
actually know she's not writer is just
one guy on the first episode and he
comes from Saturday Night Live and I
think he did like the Tonight Show or
The Daily Show like that kind of humor I
think actually makes a little bit more
sense when you're just being constantly
satirical self-referential it doesn't
necessarily work as well in fiction it
kind of feels like you're being ranted
at about a joke that you don't get it's
really odd because it just constantly
happens like the start is um
how important sincerity is in animation
you have to commit to the bit yeah
yeah even if you're being yeah yeah even
if you're being caustic even if you are
being insincere you have to be sincerely
yeah yeah you gotta go for it Harley
Quinn man uh like the opening scene of
Velma is Velma talking about
something that like I didn't like this
as an opener she's like usually An
Origin story is about a white guy
struggling with how he has more power
and I was like well couldn't we have
your origin story B something cool about
this nerdy character that a lot of
people really loved as a kid why does it
have to be about you criticizing a dude
which again is just a reference to
another TV show seen immediately
afterwards opens with a bunch of girls
in a locker room
um naked in a shower and they go isn't
it crazy how every pilot starts with
nudity so that they get ratings and
that's written oh so it's just it's just
cool
no they're doing this stuff the the
opening was velma's video but every
other part is a character just
constantly referencing something and
it's I I don't know again I don't think
it's just that bad up
but it's got a lot to answer for hasn't
it and I think it's also that Deadpool
because it exists and yes I do think
Deadpool has influenced way too many
writers but I think that Deadpool
um gets away with it because Deadpool is
so ridiculous where they're still trying
to make Velma ground did so it commits
to the bit Deadpool is doing all those
jokes but he is invested in the thing
he's trying to do he's in love he's yeah
angry that's the other thing is that
once you realize that this is motivated
by fear insecurity and driven by love
then you can do whatever you want
because you can now empathize you're not
just laughing with them you're
empathizing everything because you
realize that it's all a defense apply in
Velma because it's every single
character I think that like they tried
to make her a little unlikable at first
because she's out to prove something and
that I think works but like there's
another like there's a girl dies and the
the other random woman we don't really
know is giving a speech and she's like
usually when a [__] girl dies in TV we
think it's her fault
who asked for that comment to to be at
this it's just so odd because it's that
they aren't jokes you're just saying
things you think other TV shows do so
there are things I loved out loud out
there were things I found funny I like
the animation there are characters I
like but that constant thing that
happens every two minutes of it being
like this isn't quite satire we're just
referencing something we don't like it's
like oh my God give me a break
here's I would interject this in light
of this week in the reviews that came
out about forespoken I also want a lot
of take on that because I saw you put a
video up and I've not watched it first
hour is fine
yeah that's what I've heard from people
anyway sorry Troy I'll cut you off I
just I think that it's easy to get like
even just within this conversation the
three of us
how easily it is to
criticize totally and really hard to
make a TV show like that's it's super
hard to make a TV show and I have I have
friends that were on for spoken
and nobody knows the inside dealings and
the machinations of what that is so I I
suppose we should frame this I would
choose to frame this as this is what we
got so if this is not what you intended
as the writers as a creators to portray
to your audience then
maybe we can take that and do it in
either season two or do it in another
show that's what I would encourage
everyone who gets criticism to be able
to apply including myself if somebody
doesn't like what I do
okay it's I the way that I look at it is
this there are 50 50 split of people on
this planet some people think that
cilantro should be in everything and
other people think that cilantro tastes
like soap so I don't care about your
taste but if you didn't get what I was
putting down I didn't do my job so if
their intention was to be
self-referential and very irreverent in
doing so then you [__] accomplished
it I just don't personally like that I
think that's but if they're like
probably oh we were trying to be sincere
well then you should hear this criticism
because maybe next time tweak it a
little bit it's iterative you're right
and that's why I'm like I don't think
velma's the worst show on the planet and
I don't think it deserves the like
absolute hate bombing that it's I don't
I don't like it but I don't think it's
the worst thing that I've ever seen
um but it it definitely we don't know
the intent it comes across as though
those things that are referential are
supposed to be jokes
that is how it is framed sometimes they
even have like a joke that is is funny
and then they make one of those
references immediately afterwards and
you go
why does this happen and so I I feel
like that's consistently being received
that way across the board
um that I think it's also different when
you have people that are used to running
for one reason is that it's just a
translation of that kind of humor across
the mediums does not work the Slade in
Detroit I think they weren't even green
light for season two
this has been by the way the most fun
talking about the menu I've ever had
um
okay my internet connection is unstable
you just disappeared for a second and
came back
so I'm taking it
um I made a shitty joke doesn't matter I
do need to bounce
um but I've enjoyed greatly talking
about the menu it was a really good idea
I think you particularly bro I love
really good investigations to the table
yeah I feel like Troy's input on the
menu you laid out an amazing banquet of
opinion for us
yeah I'm upset that that that Joseph got
every damn time Ray finds
um
Shakespeare in Love yeah Josephine
should not be referenced um in this
um but I I I'm a little bit disappointed
that Ray finds did not get nominated
because I believe there's performance
perfect I think he's incredible
he's just one of those actors though
who's always very very good so I can
understand he's overlooked characters
one of my favorites like God he's so
[__] good which one in uh Grand
Budapest Hotel his character I just love
two bits it's incredible all right um
all right well we will leave it there
everybody I don't know what I'm gonna
title this episode once again look at us
go
that's my police video game director
that's Rebecca he is a podcast host and
Frozen Wait no sorry that's Mike Bethel
one of the most prolific podcast hosts
of our time oh yeah also podcast host
Troy maker me not a podcast host
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]